welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how much you
gotta
reach to fill seven videos a week when
there's literally zero movie news
20 20 what a year quite the year of
theory spinning here at new rockstars
and now that it is behind us
let us ask ourselves once again
what we got wrong it's her performance
that's the big ben selling you wrong
wrong
i thought that was the inception sound
oh yeah okay and i think it's all the
same sound
it's all palpatine's voice that was last
year hey
i'm eric voss here with me today is
philip molina
happy new year almost phillip how you
doing happy no almost new year
who are you gonna kiss at midnight your
new puppy maybe daryl might get a smooch
she might jump up and give me a smooch
and i'll have to try to train her to be
like we we don't do that we don't do
that but use positive reinforcement oh
my dog can do anything he wants did he
say her name is darla darla's her name
oh is she named after the vampire from
angel
oh i didn't know that one uh we were
thinking
maybe the piranha girl from finding nemo
who bites everything
uh or or the little rascal darla i kind
of like the little rascal darling
she's a little rascal that's cute hey
eric this is your performance review
yes each year you live or die based on
how
how this goes that said you know what
this year
do we really need to to make you swim in
your failure
do we that's you know what like we all
had such a rough year that
i don't want to make you i don't want to
rub your nose and
and make you learn lessons whatever you
did a great job this year
you did the best with what you could i
appreciate that um
it was a very tough year um but i think
it is
fair for us to go through this because
there were some
things i could improve upon there were
some big swings i took you know what
it's gonna be fun next year phillip
because i made a lot of predictions for
the 2021 movies
and this time next year uh it may be
me running for the border you think
you're you're going to get deported
based on your baby
i didn't say which border i'm going to
nevada to make some bets
that's true okay that's fine then
because if you are down to do it then we
do have a list that i think we did
prepare
everything you got wrong okay you know i
mean if you really want to get into it
i will say that i appreciate the
the swings you take no matter how hard
you whiff it sometimes
but i'm specifically i'm going to let
you off easy on one uh one thing for
sure
i'm not going to count any of your
insane batshit theories from rogue
theory
because i love those i think everybody
needs to go
insane bat [ __ ] on rogue theory it's a
competition show that's challenging you
to go
rogue or some of our comments or spell
it rouge
however there are some exceptions
sometimes you go
real bad [ __ ] you go you know full on
guano
and then you double down and you make a
blue screen video
out of it and that means that you had us
hire an editor
to put in graphics and spend their whole
day you know away from their family so
they could put
your batshit theory
up on the internet for a bunch of people
to see yeah so that means that you are
saying yeah uh-huh
i i think that is worth taking poor josh
away from his nine children
to make my bachelor theory into a video
hey hey sometimes the world just needs
to see
i guess we should call it an rt double d
uh an r
uh rogue theory double down hashtag rtdt
uh hey i did rt
i saw everything horrible that happened
at star wars
okay fair that is fair because i do
believe those theories and if i'm wrong
i should have to eat crow for it
so let's get started eric uh first of
all um as any good performance review
starts
how do you think you did this year i
think i did
oh tay um i know
okay yeah because here's the deal a
little rascal references
there's gonna be a lot of alfalfa this
episode the
it's hard to um say because like we had
so
few things to to judge it by luckily at
the end of the year we had things like
the boys to talk about we had the
mandalorian to talk about
but like a lot of the movies that we
were making predictions for for 2020
all got delayed so i don't know it's i'm
i'm i'm curious to know what you
discovered that i cause there's a couple
things i know i screwed up but i
i know there's some things that i
overlook so i don't really know
number one 20 20.
you completely got 20 20 wrong oh just a
year
all kinds of theories about how this
movie will release in march and we'll
all go see black widow
and we'll have a sleepover scary one and
then we'll watch
new mutants and none of that happened i
think well new mutants happened
but most people didn't know it didn't
happen in the way that that you said
that it would
tenant all these things that you were
like oh the theatrical experience will
show us this
and this and you were completely wrong
movies died
on your watch what have you to say for
yourself
uh apologize i do
uh that was weird the um you are
right to bring this up well one because
i am coveted patient zero
i coughed on a lot of people in wuhan
they asked me to stop and i said this
will be okay
and uh literal bat [ __ ] that's what
happened there
uh but no no no the this is a valid
point to bring up because i did kind of
make a lot of predictions based on the
release order of things and i said that
like kevin feige had this meticulous
release order plan
that there's no way falcon winter
soldier will come out before
widow is essential it's essential they
can't do anything without black widow
i did make some theories that black
widow would definitely set up the falcon
winter soldier which would definitely
set up eternals you know and
and all that all that got moved around
um so and obviously it doesn't matter um
is coming out like two months before
black widow we hope in 2021
so um yeah i i definitely flubbed that
okay cool
just want you to acknowledge it all
right but now let's get specific
item one a all right the mandalorian
season two
that just wrapped up very recently it
was very emotional no i'm not crying
you're crying and a lot of our
commenters uh wanted this called out and
wanted you to answer for this sin
uh and this was your weird idea
that the eggs that the frog lady was
dealing with
had to do with groga's own amphibious
nature
and specifically the moment that
everybody just harped on so much is your
idea that
the eggs were like attracted to him in
the jar rather than
he was just using the forest that he was
trying to eat them eggs
okay you may think it's crazy but men's
health thought it was a cool idea
because i
got featured in let's help you were in
men's health you were in
esquire why why why i
they're obviously in desperate need of
consciousness does this look like a
healthy man to you
mentally unwell um yeah so
philip and i have talked about this off
screen before this was a mistake i made
of not making sure that all of our
viewers know exactly what's running
through my mind when i'm pitching a
theory
the first time we talked about this
episode obviously i knew grogan was
using the force to move those eggs
toward him
but then when i made another video i
just neglected to mention the fact that
grogan might just be using the force to
do it so everyone's just like does this
guy really think that those
unfertilized eggs are sentient beings
who recognize this little puppet
and in retrospect it did look kind of
stupid
in my defense um what i will say is we
still don't know a lot about grosgu
could still have an amphibious origin he
still might recognize these eggs from
his home world
he was just using the force to eat them
he was probably just hungry
but that music man you heard the that
music come back in the final episode
right like that was the same music for
his goodbyes he's a frog boy
frog philip has that mary steenburgen
disease where he just hears weird music
in his head at all times
it's not named after it's also not a
disease it's just a condition it's a
gift
honestly it is i love mary steve virgin
i think she's great
she wrote a musical because she has this
people have no idea what we're talking
about but it's very much much like
phineas gage but yeah with music it's
like that scrubs episode you're the only
man who's ever been inside of me
but uh yeah yeah he might still have
like an amphibious background he might
have hatched from an egg he might
um i know it's might might might none of
that is confirmed eric i get it i get it
i get it but i think it's not
a crazy theory to say that grogu might
have recognized his favorite snack food
from his home planet
just then but we'll see i could come
back in 2021 and be like
again yeah eggs it's just such a weird
thing to
to bet the farm on we're just like at
the farm
yeah frog boy his favorite snack is
a woman's ex i mean we all been there
though am i right yeah if i blame
anything it's the choice of music the
music is just so
beautiful in that moment and if it was
like a goofy moment as it's supposed to
be why didn't they have like
like that's the doug goof around music
do they have that ever in the
mandalorian they don't have goof around
music
no but they should every show needs goof
around music classic cece winston mess
around
that's not a thing can we play a very
serious moment from the mandalorian but
put in that stupid music
it was more fun okay moving on 1b
you just sticking with grogu here for a
second this is a very
oddly specific prediction you had you
thought grogu would not only
wield the darksaber which we later
learned would make him the rightful
ruler of mandalore it turns out why do
you think i came all this way
but you also thought that he would
wield it in such a specific way that he
would use it to stab
moff gideon in the eye you'll shoot your
eye out kid
now i want you to remember that
this is basically a sword and your
theory even if it wasn't the dark saber
would be that somebody was gonna put a
sword
specifically through mob gideon's eye
and it would be this little baby
uh-huh it would have been really cool if
he did though right
oh no doubt that's my defense of like 90
of my theories it would have been cool
no doubt i'll accept that defense oh
thank you yeah i know it didn't happen
it's like it would have been the most
insane [ __ ] ever if it's just like grog
is just like
yeah what i was like head is just pinned
into the wall i thought what was gonna
happen was like if this was gonna go
down
it would have been a fight he would have
been like and then amanda would have
forced back the dark saber with the best
scar spear and then just like randomly
grogu would have like
moved his hands back before he could
retract the blade and it would have gone
in his eye gogu would have put a piece
of gum
in the handle and then he'd be like what
is going on and then goku uses the force
hey there's still time left could still
be that scene from the sixth century
you want to see my dad you want to play
with my dad's dark saber
saber gash dark saber gash i have a lot
of fond memories here
um not since pornhub removed everything
that wasn't from verified creators
um i i accept those and i accept your
apology uh for now uh moving on we're
gonna do a quick
rest over at the boys i just really want
to quickly call out here on your hr
complaints form
that uh you thought the secret soup uh
who popped the heads was the
poor bearded extra in the background and
you also thought that the fly would be
so important
that you had fly watch on the boys after
show
uh it was going to be the identity of
swato you made once again you made
poor tommy track this fly and
appearances of any flies he went insane
and never paid off
and that poor bearded extra he'll never
work again because of what you said
oh yeah i feel bad for that dude or he's
trying to like hey
i got to be zoomed in on in a new
rockstars video that's cool i'm gonna
wear this beard that's what you do if
you're ever like working in the extra
business always have like some kind of
weird feature or whatever
people will point you out and be like
hey that's that dude no this is true
if you're in a crowd shot or whatever
always have two things one a strong
reaction and
interact with somebody else yep yep
it always works they will always focus
on you just so you know or if you're in
a marvel movie
wear a hot topic skirt with a web
pattern and everyone will think you're
gwen stacy
and they have to use you in in uh yeah
with the boys i totally whiffed on the
call of who that head popper was the
show did such a good job of hiding the
fact that it was congresswoman newman
um they like even to the point of having
her character development go in the
complete opposite direction i honestly
think philip in season three
that a lot of people would be like wait
that doesn't make any sense
it is kind of like one of those big
things like hux and the rise of
skywalker where
he's like i'm the spy and everyone's
like whoa didn't see that coming but
wait a minute
huh he blew up a start system yeah
exactly but uh we don't ask those
questions
we just enjoy it um no but that's fine i
just want you to apologize to both that
fly and the bearded man yes but you can
use the same apology for both uh okay
because they are the same character is
that what you're saying philip oh
well we got wrong 2021 bearded flywatch
the bearded fly watch step right up
let's see the better fly
it's already uh crazy i'm sorry
fly i'm sorry extra i wish you were the
head popper that would have been really
cool right
man what a cool role that'd be would it
have been cool if some random extra was
like this big villain the whole time i
would have been uh
if it were that guy would have been like
what
okay awesome yeah all right so uh moving
on to this is one of your um
bigger swings and you you really took a
lot of heat for this and then you were
dead wrong so
i just you know really made sure to take
this moment uh and save it for the
for later in the year the justice league
snyder cut so there was this whole
release of snyder cut campaign
and a lot of passionate people working
really hard and and just dedicating
themselves to this thing
and you said that it was all a hoax
it never existed there was no snyder cut
and it would never be released
and that the hashtag was uh the
imaginary thinking of just a very small
group that was just very vocal on social
media
uh roll the clip it's essentially a
conspiracy theory not always a terrible
one
but my theory on this is is i think this
is essentially
a much much smaller movement than
the media and that social media in
particular is making it out to be
it's not a real news story it's
manufactured and i feel like if we were
to talk about it
on social media specifically use that
hashtag we're just playing into like a
small contingency of people who are just
trying to use us
to further that message and i don't want
to be part of that keep rolling the clip
roll more of that clip
come on no dude we're not watching a
whole episode of rogue theory
inside of this or you could just put a
period at the end of the sentence
that's what a lot of people say no uh
yeah okay
so here's the deal um i first off and
you'll see if you go watch that episode
please watch it i do
say that i wanted there to be a great
snyder cut of justice league that was
true to how great dc comics are
because as someone who grew up reading
dc comics i was always more of a dc guy
i loved batman comics
i read far more dc comics than i did
marvel comics as a kid i thought marvel
comics in the 90s were weird i was like
i don't know what this x-force is it's
freaking me out and weird
and i really only read frank miller's
daredevil uh because
i had known frank miller from his batman
graphic novels so i was like this guy's
great
so i did say that it was an overblown
social media movement
and we would never see the snyder cut i
did also
think and i think i was right about this
that there wasn't an actual watchable
snyder cut that you could just
release by a click of a button or a wave
of a wand
some people would say the weeding cut
isn't watchable either you won't let me
live
you won't let me die some people might
say that the snyder cut is unwatchable
once it's done
we'll see we will see i think it'll be
better
for sure than the weeding cut i don't
know if it will be
good i don't know if it will fix all the
problems that were there just based off
what i know about what snyder actually
did one i i don't know if that would be
perfect why won't it be it'll be longer
it'll be more it'll be kind of like the
the ultimate edition of batman v
superman
i guess it was better but it was really
at the end of the day just more of
batman v
superman and snyder's vision don't let
your dreams be dreams
i love his visual style there are some
issues with like story beats that i'm
not
crazy about with the way he like
structures his scripts you can't you
can't start taking apart
zack snyder's work while you're supposed
to be apologizing to him for second
guessing him
apologies to zack snyder uh apologies to
zack snyder and all everyone who tweeted
released a snyder cut because clearly
your movement was successful
you uh you accomplished what i thought
was impossible and you got this movie
you got warner's attention you had my
curiosity
now you have my attention however i
think there was a smaller group of very
very successful people getting the word
out about this
but was it millions strong no and we
have the numbers on our end to prove
that this was a
truly grassroots small movement that was
very effective at
amplifying their message rather than
actually getting like
hardcore believers of a million people
or something
what do you mean you have the numbers
what what work did you put in
did you hire someone to look into all
these people
well for one we had the petition the
petition didn't garner
more than 10 percent of the number of
people who signed the petition to
reshoot game of thrones season 8.
more than i can say for this lot get
these prisoners to work
and no video about the snyder cut that
we have made on this channel has got
more than a million views which tells
you something and
that's when there have been trailers
that have come out when they've been
huge
news you still think it's a hoax it's a
fake
i don't think it's a hoax i just think
it's actually a smaller group of people
who want it than it seems
but you're the first person that's to
want a snyder cut vaccine too
hey i do i don't think that's a hug pump
me
pump me if i get the vaccine i have to
go outside again
i don't want to go outside other
mistakes you've made this is my favorite
time of year
the movie tenet you built it up over
a year of building this movie up saying
that it was going to be
game changing it was going to change
cinema it was going to change
the concept of time travel not just in
in film but just in general like the
ways that people could travel through
time
so it's going to use this form called
the inverted body uh time travel also
known as
pear-shaped but a form of time travel
that's never
been shown in movies before and it's
just gonna blow everybody's [ __ ] mind
and that's maybe the only part that's
true is that that movie did destroy
so many brain cells for so many people
but it was kind of a normal time travel
thing yeah i don't believe it
at all you know what philip you are
right i uh you saw my trailer breakdowns
i found that like law of entropy
on a dry erase board some of them this
is
uh this is gonna be uh epic and they
talked about entropy i really
thought we we cracked the code of it and
they had the red and the blue chamber
i'm like this is just like maxwell's
thought experiment that he had
written on a dry erase board in the
trailer that might have informed nolan's
research
and it obviously did nolan understood
laws of thermodynamics it was clearly
like
in the subtext of the movie but it was
not at no point did someone do a doc
brown and draw like a timeline on a
board
uh it was all rushed explanations spoken
through
uh masks that made it hard for us to
hear them um
but to be clear to be fair it's possible
that it was what you said and no one
heard it
what did you say punk really what we
found while we watched it spoiler
warning for tenant it
was a different form of time travel that
we described as this always happened
time travel
where like the act of time travel is
something that has always happened in a
predestined loop
you know it from the prisoner of azkaban
you know how harry
knew that time travel was the answer
because he realized the past version of
himself had been helping him
that's kind of what tenet is the
difference is and i guess you could say
this is mind-blowing
rather than the act of time travel being
something that happens real fast that
you travel
through the timeline and appear
instantaneously at the new point in the
timeline
tenet forces you to relive in real time
just in reverse order
that whole history until you get back to
a reset turnstile point
so it's a more tedious version of time
travel than we've ever seen
on screen before uh visually stunning
but
conceptually mind-blowing yeah it's up
for debate
no thanks
that you were wrong i was wrong now i
want to be clear the list
of things that you got wrong is endless
egregious
and a danger to mankind but we only have
so much time
so i just want to pick one more that our
audience was really demanding your head
for
uh and that's that you said that you
knew who the villain of she-hulk was
gonna be
you put it all online and you said that
it was gonna be
daddy thunderbolt ross is gonna come
back as red hulk you've been pushing
that you're the biggest william hurt fan
in the world apparently you're like
this guy needs to be jacked bloated
red and thick and veiny and that's i'm
waiting for that you kept pushing it
and you were wrong it turns out wrong
sir
wrong but i will give you not the
craziest
distance from what ended up happening
finding out that abomination is gonna
come back
and not thunderbolt losses yeah um i was
completely shocked that they brought
back abomination for this
it was something that we did another
video talking about all the the villains
who might still be alive in the mcu
abomination was on that list
is because in a reddit ama kevin feige
teased this like back in 2017
he's like abomination is still in a you
know in a prison cell somewhere
you might show back up and we're like
yeah whatever but the fact that they're
bringing it back i hope they do a
redesign for him
even if it means like doing a retcon to
make that character
a form of red hulk that would be really
cool you see me i'm still pushing for it
i think he looks i thought abomination
was you still just want the red bloated
guy
abomination was uh yeah he was too
desaturated
to not enough of a face it was just too
much of a monster to latch on to
anything visually i like that he had
bones that was cool like the
the stab the elbow stab that was cool
yeah i hope that they still keep up this
red hulk thing that thunderbolt ross
comes back in some future property
uh as red hulk that would be cool but
yeah it's a bit much to say that he's
gonna be
in a half hour legal thriller comedy
on disney plus sorry jennifer walters
he's gonna bring back
uh william hurt uh just like you're like
for a sitcom where he's like all right
i'm red hulk now no one asked any
questions uh happy birthday
he keeps leading is this boston legal or
is this
yeah freaking world war hulk if there's
any other things that you want eric to
answer to
feel free to tweet at him at tommy beck
told uh
just with all your hate and he will
we'll take it and i'll answer each one
one by one
uh but those are just some of the
highlights uh eric the
much crazier theories uh that you
pitched in 2020 are for titles that
turned out didn't even come out
this year so we still don't even know
but i want to put them up on the board
uh just so that you have to answer to
these somebody's going to
keep track of all this not me i'm you
know only interested for the shaming
part
so let's go and do the things that are
are wait and see how bad you [ __ ] them
up
uh-oh these are the ones i am actually
very worried about because this is stuff
where it's like a
rainy day and i was just swung for the
fences
before we get to these um because i
might have to jump out the window during
these i
i actually want to thank some friends
who helped us make this out you're
stalling uh we want to thank our friends
at doordash for helping us make this
episode
one thing we didn't get wrong this year
was using doordash to order delicious
food no office meant no
office wide chipotle fridays with
producer zach running up to pick up
readables well the doordash
chipotle fridays are alive and well
doordash is the app that brings you the
food you're craving right now
right to your door ordering so easy you
just open the doordash app you choose
what you want to eat your food will be
left safely outside your door with a new
contactless delivery drop-off setting
with over 300 000 partners in the us and
puerto rico canada and australia
you can support your local go-to's or
choose from your favorite national
restaurants like chipotle
hey wendy's ho ho and the cheesecake
factory yes yes
uh many of your favorite local
restaurants are still open for delivery
just open the door dash app select your
favorite local restaurant and your food
will be left at your door
jordas deliveries are now contactless to
keep communities we operate in safe
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off and zero delivery fees on
their first order
of 15 or more when you download the
doordash app and enter the code
big question that's five dollars off and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter the code big
question don't forget that's code big
question for five dollars off your first
order with doordash
we also want to thank our friends at
mint mobile for sponsoring this episode
if you use
a big wireless provider do you really
know what you're paying for
do you because i get overcharged on
those big carriers all the time
between expensive retail stores their
inflated prices their hidden fees
you are being taken advantage of all the
time because they just know
you gonna pay it because you're with us
well enter
mint mobile mint mobile's great they
provide the same premium network
coverage that you're used to
but at a fraction of the cost because
everything is online they save on retail
locations
and overhead that these other big dumb
companies have to cover
and they pass all those savings onto you
mobile companies are
kind of like cable companies or power
companies right like nobody really likes
them but you don't really have a choice
it feels like
well mint mobile gives you that choice
which i love they're changing the game
mint mobile makes it easy to cut your
wireless bill down to just 15
bucks a month can you believe that 50
bucks a month imagine paying 15 bucks a
month on your cell phone bill
every plan comes with unlimited
nationwide talk and text with mint
mobile stop paying for unlimited data
that you'll never use you can choose
between plans with three
or eight or 12 gigabytes of 4g lte
data and you can use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan
and keep your same phone number along
with all your existing contacts so ditch
your old wireless bill and start saving
with mint mobile
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
bigq that's mintmobile.com bigq cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
midmobile.com
big q we also want to thank our friends
at calm 2020 has been
a lot and we could all benefit from less
stress and more sleep in our lives it's
so important to take care of yourself
and invest in our well-being during
times of anxiety that is why we are
excited to partner with calm and that is
the app designed to help
ease your stress and get the best sleep
of your life and when you relieve
anxiety and improve your sleep you feel
better in every part of your life calm
has a whole library of programs designed
for healthy sleep like soundscapes
guided meditations
over a hundred sleep stories narrated by
soothing voices like stephen fry
kelly roland laura dern over 85 million
people around the world use calm to take
care of their minds and get better sleep
and for listeners of this show calm is
offering a special
limited time promotion of forty percent
off a calm premium subscription
at com.com bigquestion that is a forty
percent off unlimited access to calm's
entire library
and new content is added every week get
started today at calm.com
bigquestion that's calm.com big question
did you just insert an entire ad break
just to delay
having an answer for your stupid
theories yes it's a delay tactic did it
work
uh absolutely um i i calmed down once
you talked about that sweet sweet mint
mobile
it's a great deal yeah i actually am a
big fan of doordash because
they are letting us do something insane
uh that i
i can't talk to any of you yet even you
eric
eve it heavily involves you we'll talk
about it off camera
nope it'll be on camera you'll see all
right
all right whatever that is let's answer
the question of what are your most
insane maybe [ __ ] theories that are
still wait and see and they're still
from 2020 but you got lucky because they
got delayed and
you might be completely wrong okay but
we don't know just yet you ready
yeah let's do it all right number one
one division you have
said it time and time again so many
times
everything is mephisto that's mephisto
that puppy is mephisto the wall is
mephisto my fist is mephisto
everything is mephisto you could be
right yeah you're
probably going to be wrong and
everything we'll see uh i
have not said literally everything i've
not said your fist is mephisto without
doing good i have said your sister's
mobisto
that's a good one your sister mephistic
system my sister my piston
what we'll see look this is another one
where it's like i really want it to be
true
and a lot of people i don't know where
they're getting this some people have
said
this just even happened in the comics so
he's like no there is a west coast
adventure series in the 80s
where wanda has these fake kids
with vision and there is a witch who
helps them look after them
and those kids are revealed to be
illusory puppets of another force who
was being
operated by mephisto i i think that's
where they're coming from here i think
they're saying it's similar to the
vision nuclear family comics
uh the the king ones uh or that it's
house of m
i don't think we're gonna get the house
of m yet um but you are right
mephisto has not been in any literal
form in any footage so far
i'm i'm fine with mephisto showing up
yeah i think mephisto showing up is
super interesting i think your theory of
everything is though is
oh i don't think everything's mephisto i
just think it's oh he admitted it
it's like the line in ratatouille not
everyone can
become a great artist but a great artist
can come from anywhere not everyone is
mephisto but
mephisto can't come from anywhere annie
versus every
i think any of these one things might be
evidence of mephisto's corruptive
influence but
i get it i know i sound kind of crazy
saying that is that
is that is that is er probably not
everything is uh moving on to
uh also kind of related to one division
uh another
big swing you're taking is that you said
one division
spider-man three and doctor strange two
are all a big
multiverse crisis that's going to tie in
the
alternate spider verses but the
live-action ones
and potentially uh which all sounds
honestly like it might happen
but then you also tied in this thing
randomly that tony stark is going to
appear as
an alternate source for spring which
kind of like why did you tag that on you
were doing so well
because um if you put iron man in
anything people like it more
i think that's why that's your for your
theory or your thumbnail or what
yeah that's for the thumbnail um philip
is referring to our um
our big finale of rogue theory last week
this is like my big master theory for
2020 definitely go check out that
episode it's bit it like it was so
awesome the way that episode went down
but yeah it's my big multiverse theory
i don't know how many of these things
are going to tie into it i feel like
multiverse is the answer for spider-man
3.
the fact that doctor strange is going to
be in it and that sam raimi has been it
sounds like instrumental in getting all
these other spider-verse villains and
characters in it here we go
rounding the corner with a bunch of
spider-man here we are manhattan can you
handle it
and he's directing doctor strange too i
think those two movies are gonna be
pretty tied together
uh and they said wanda is gonna be a
character who comes back in the dr
strange two movie so
based on all that i feel like those
three movies are intertwined i don't
think that's too crazy
but uh tony stark coming back might be a
bit of a reach
i only say that just because we want to
see him come back it would be so easy
just to have archived footage of an
alternate reality tony stark because
they have a
video and set photo of when they were
going to do a bit infinity war
where tony stark was going to wear the
cloak of levitation and they could just
literally drag and drop
rotoscope like they did mark hamill's
face and throw that on a stand in
on a green screen and boom you've got
just like a quick image if someone just
looks through a bunch of different
portals he could be on the other side of
one of the portals and then my theory it
works
the special effects artists are cringing
so hard at your description of what
their job is
we're just gonna drag and drop yeah
that's how those oswald pictures are
faked
like you know the conspiracy on that
it's like you just drag and drop and you
create a conspiracy
hey some of those conspiracy photos are
literal just drag and drop
like remember there was that uh deadpool
on the set of
of endgame photo people were like oh my
god deadpool's gonna be in him we're
like
it's just him on set from deadpool one
to total fabrication or whenever we
pretend tommy's still alive
yeah um okay so uh uh and then also
related to all these upcoming series
falcon the winter soldier you said that
okay this isn't the craziest idea it's
not like tony stark is gonna be in his
search of supreme stupid but
it's uh that cap gave sam a special
shield
that has some features that only sam can
activate
yeah i i like like cap this is the thin
shield that somewhere in there it has
all this tech
that cap did not related to tony stark
because this is where he lived his own
separate life and then hands off this
this shield
so like in his own garage he put in some
i never said it was
i never said it was cap but i said he
knows about it
because here's just so people know and
it is a crazy theory you're right but
this is a new shield it has a different
design there are little notches in it
and they're weird like hexagonal
pentagonal tiles in it
that look like they could be like
removable
in a way and i think that there's a
reason he gave it to sam and not bucky
and i think it's because bucky already
has his winter soldier arm that's made
of
vibranium i think this shield is gonna
be made out of like proto-adamantium or
something because we know
or at least we think cap lived in like
an alternate history and i think in that
alternate history he like
made some cool friends who hooked him up
with a really cool shield
he's gonna be like sam wilson's gonna do
some great stuff
every time i call you out on your theory
you like make like well yeah i'm just
saying you know how you see the shield
proto adamantium and it's like
yeah that's a fine theory the idea that
it's got like this
special version that only works for sam
but also your theory that he's like
sam and bucky's dad and it's like well
bucky you already have a mental arm
i gotta give something to sam now uh
yeah you are you are voicing the
concerns of
a big contention of our viewers who are
like i was with you for the first half
of the video
they had us the first half i'm not gonna
lie and then after the ad break you said
and then i stopped watching at the ad
break
pretty much you also said that this show
was gonna introduce
so many characters they said wolverine
would get introduced in falcon winter
soldier
ultron and the thunderbolts it's
possible
it is possible yeah it's possible
[Music]
we'll see right it's coming out in march
the i think wolverine we're going to
madrapore which is so cool that they
introduced that in the trailer right
like
what a cool setting i love it in the
marvel universe where they introduced
these like
places on earth that we didn't know were
there whether it's sokovia or wakanda
now we got another one so it's like oh
we're not going to berlin or london now
it's like
they can really do some world building
so with magipore there's a lot of
potential tie-ins with mutants
and i i think that could be a place that
ties in wolverine if not in this show
maybe in a future installment like
secret invasion or something we'll see
remind you that this is the list of
things that you guys are going to hold
eric to as these things come
out and just make him pay dearly if he
gets these wrong
they'll pay for this real quick let's uh
fly through some of these black widow
ones
uh you said that natasha is going to
surgically swap faces with elena biloba
that that still could happen yes
honestly um so
i i hope it does kind of but
i don't know if i wanted to stay that
way i don't know but it could happen
yeah
what i don't think will ever happen is
that ivan vanco or uh
whiplash is going to be revealed to be
natasha's father i think it's weird
that you think that all russian people
are related right and only one person
can have the name ivan in russia
ivan dragon one of them is her dad
i do deserve to be called out for this
one uh this was a one of those rainy day
theories and i think a lot of it was
like this was kind of blowing up
on social media people were asking us
about it and we're like let's just do a
video to explain how it would be
possible because
that journey is interesting to talk
about but the conclusion
is not the case he is not her dad and i
don't want whiplash to come back to the
episode yeah
god what a weird choice so but those are
all silly there are two predictions you
made for
uh for black widow that i hate
and i just i'm like no that better not
be true
uh they're both related to the same
thing they're both related to natasha
dying
one is uh you said that you thought that
maybe tony stark
traded his life or hers when he snapped
i hope not
uh that'd be weird you know what i think
i based this on uh before we
knew that there was an actual scene with
him talking to morgan stark
in his uh orange film and then that
footage came out
uh so i was like oh but i had a theory
that he talked to
natasha romanov or was met with her in
that moment he's like i'm gonna trade my
life for years
and that she would be brought back to
life on voromir and wake up in that soul
puddle
because it's all connected to the soul
stone nope no
it's not yeah it's probably nothing and
i'm glad that they they did not listen
to you on that uh yeah and then also
very similar as she was falling to her
dad
she was like wait a second and she said
that out loud and then she checked her
pocket and she's like
i still got pin particles and then she
goes and like decides to travel and go
have the entire black widow movie
go live all of those events and then i
guess bring herself back
into it and then let herself finish
dying that's your theory yep that was
a weird one how dare you hey i just
really want to like ruin that death
scene
i here's the deal you know how much i
love time travel my
end game goal for all of new rockstars
videos is to find a way to work time
travel into every theory because i
love it and i love finding new ways to
do it and end games time travel logic
was
so weird and so broken that i will
always try to find weird ways to exploit
it
why not make it worse you know i thought
it was fine
call me crazy i liked avengers end game
i like the movie
logic makes no sense speaking of uh time
travel logic and characters that you
make weird big swings about it's always
tony stark related too
you said that tony stark secretly knew
about kang the conqueror
and battled him off screen not even this
is why he made it this is so crazy
not even like in a movie we never got to
see or some scientist
during the events of avengers endgame
you're like oh yeah and then he also off
screen was battling kang the conqueror
but you know they thought maybe let's
save that for a coloring book or
something not put it in a movie
philip you are going to be so
stupid when that reveals to be true uh
you're gonna be like i'm so sorry
can we cut that from the video you know
you're gonna feel like
no you're right okay look this is
another example of a theory that is
really
cool to think about but probably not
plausible
and i based this on the fact that tony
stark knew a lot more about the infinity
stones and about time travel
before we saw his character supposedly
learn about time travel like there was
that wakandaphiles book where he's like
talking all about time travel and all
these ramifications of time travel that
uh he was far more wise about it so it
led me to believe that
did this guy explore alternate timelines
somewhere off screen during avengers end
game uh
time does jump forward they were
supposedly working on that quantum
tunnel for months
they all had enough time to change their
clothes before they had hulk snap the
gauntlet
so if they had enough time to do that
couldn't they
couldn't they i think the big detail
philip that we still don't have answers
on are there are
other dates on that quantum tunnel
device when nebula works on it
things that go back to 2009 things that
go back to 2988 bc
so clearly they did more time traveling
in avengers end game than we saw on
screen
that's the only part that i like about
your theory is that
there may have been other events that
took place and we'll find out later
the part where where why doesn't tony
even talk about it
tony doesn't even go like hey by the way
i'm dealing with some stuff he doesn't
want them to worry
he's just a good guy also uh fantastic
four speaking of traveling
to another time and having a whole story
this one is actually my only theory of
yours that i
my only time i've ever liked something
you've said in my life um
and this is uh because i'm super on
board for this uh it's about to have a
tweet for it but you said that you think
that
hank pym's friends in the 1960s will be
revealed to have been
the fantastic four that got stuck in the
quantum realm maybe even in that hidden
city
uh and that they'll come back in
present-day uh mcu
in their upcoming film the only tweak i
have is that i don't want them to come
back to present day i would love the
whole thing to take place in the 60s
and just stay there that could be really
fun my only uh
quibble with that would be like well
then why didn't more people know about
them why didn't uh
coulson have trading cards for them you
know if they were these people
i i needed some kind of they died
terribly if they had some crazy crazy
death
i think in my theory i was like i need
an excuse to get them
out of the 60s before they got famous so
that you know the world kind of didn't
know their names yet
um but i i hope this is the case too uh
you and i have talked about this a lot
because it has come up in a bunch of my
theories
really i'm we're borrowing it from
peyton reed peyton reed said he pitched
a fantastic four movie to fox back in
the day
which was gonna be like a hard day's
night style 60s romp through new york
with a fantastic four
uh which sounds great and peyton reed
they're giving him the keys to the
castle with ant-man 3 quantomania
disney loves this guy he directed the
finale episode of the mandalorian such a
great episode so
clearly uh peyton reed's gonna factor
into the future of a lot of disney
titles in the future
maybe it'll be uh john watts is
directing the fantastic four i know but
i i think it might still be set up with
ant-man 3. moving on
the batman you have this big theory that
the riddler isn't going to be the actual
villain
and i think actually this is one of your
cooler theories that it's actually going
to be the court of owls and my favorite
part about it is i think that part's
fine
but i like how you think that they've
been manipulating batman
to actually kind of be their kind of
talon-esque
executioner and he doesn't even realize
he's playing for the wrong team
yeah i hope that's the case right um
because it does sound like this is going
to deal with like the history of the uh
the wayne family
and how they're part of the problem and
uh that'd be a cool version of the
batmobile we haven't seen before we
won't know about that until 2022 though
and then one of your
uh smaller swings and there's a kind of
pun here is that you think there's
another mjolnir out there
um that's going back to uh marvel and
going to the upcoming thor movie and you
think jane foster is wielding
a backup version of meow meow that was
secretly made on nitvaleer
that they again they're just you know
all those moments that they just don't
show on screen when they're like oh my
god hold it open
we have you know the ability to make
storm breaker real quick
let's also quickly make a backup version
of mule near 2 real fast and i'll show
that
yeah yeah we'll see i think they're
going to have to explain how
the hell mjolnir is back in this reality
or maybe 11 thunder takes place in a
different reality where mjolnir was not
destroyed by
hella but it's weird that that's the
prop they had natalie portman hold on
2019 comic-con right
i still think it'd be fun if cap never
returned male near to
that timeline because he like leaves
with it and he just screws over that
he's like there you go jane foster tap
do you have do you have mjolnir and he's
like
no i'm calling to it it's calling better
[Music]
you said that um in that hulk
specifically bruce banner is going to
use that stupid
joke of being able to make yourself
younger with the quantum tech
and like turn something to a baby and
he's going to use that to make himself
pre-hulk bruce banner which i don't know
why he would do that he's in such a
wonderful place where he gets to be
thick ass hulk and smart right now he
can't
fight man well he can buy shoes but he
can't wear
shoes phillip and if we learned anything
from 2020 it's that you need to wear
vesty sneakers they're great they fit
your foot like a sock
i haven't worn shoes in a year what are
shoes
why are shoes shoes shoes shoes shoes
shoes thanos sword oh no don't bring
this one up this is a weird theory okay
this is so weird you thought that again
you always think these like insane
things are happening actually like this
one though
but that thanos when he throws his sword
through the quantum tunnel where he's
like destroying it
that the sword actually goes through the
quantum tunnel pops out the other side
and then just like kills uncle ben or
something
ben would be great that's a great idea
that's the story well you said it was
just going to murder an extra because
you hate extras
uh yeah um that's a crazy theory
especially since the sword doesn't have
pin particles i think the logic i used
was that it has some
weird magic on it that thanos has some
kind of telekinetic link to it
and that you don't need pin particles to
access the quantum realm
you just need it to navigate the quantum
realm i'm an idiot but okay speaking of
your idiot brain
sometimes it's a pretty good idiot
yeah because there are times you get
some stuff uh right
and i want to uh acknowledge some wins
that you've had and some wins that
you've brought new rock stars and that
i'm very
proud of being associated with and
taking credit for specifically maybe the
most famous one
this is a list of some things you got
right eric
you got james gunn to tweet good work at
us
because of your easter egg uh analysis
of guardians of the galaxy you found
a big piece of that long time hidden uh
easter egg in the film
related to quill's mom why don't you
quickly tell us about that yeah it
sounds like
so james gunn hid this uh famous easter
egg in guardians of the galaxy they said
no one has fully found yet and according
to him i got closer than anyone else has
gotten
uh there's been a lot of other people
online people like mt who's been on the
show this year
um and other there's like a whole
discord server that's dedicated to
finding this
they've been able to make some progress
in decoding
um what the coordinates translate to
that you see throughout the movie
and i uh in our analysis kind of talked
about how there's a connection with the
soundtrack with these coordinates with
meredith quill and that meredith quill
might be some kind of cosmic entity or
that she might not fully be dead
even though you know in the movie they
say that her human form died
i think she might be some kind of space
goddess james gonna shot down
that she's lady death or eternity but
there might be some other kind of new
figure that he's introduced don't don't
add on theories that might make you
wrong
take the win take the double take the
win i think our analysis uh definitely
gave people a scope of what the theory
is that people hadn't been able to do
yet
now that made uh james gunn tweet good
job but
you also made james gunn tweet this
[ __ ]
when you found the villain sorrow in uh
the sizzle reel imagery in the suicide
squad
he did not tweet that uh i don't or if
he probably didn't want to
give us any kind of attention the fact
that we found it but we totally found
starro
uh in suicide squad i feel super proud
of this one like i went through that
sizzle reel
frame by frame a lot of people were like
oh we're not even talking about this
it's just a sizzle reel
they edited it so deceptively to try to
hide
any details and after like the morning
of i had already shot a video about this
i was looking through it again i slacked
john i read it i'm like
john i just found starro in this he's
like who's taro and i'm like it's the
guy
it's a starface latching villain from dc
and i found a couple spots where you can
see it
and uh yeah he's there he's gonna be the
villain yeah and then real quick i wanna
uh just list some of the stuff that i
think like most people thought was gonna
happen but i do have to give you credit
for
you did predict that luke skywalker
would show up in the mandalorian
you did also predict that secret
invasion would be
a nick fury series in development but
that did kind of seem like where things
were headed
uh and you also were able to tell that
stormfront was an ageless nazi and boys
but it kind of seemed like a lot of
people guessed that too
but sure you still get points for all of
those any thoughts on that yeah um
i think with each of those a lot of
people did think it was going that way
but anytime i talked about it i i feel
protective of these uh
theories because i did mention them
early on and i had so many people say
the [ __ ] is this guy talking about shut
up you're just reading it
you're saying that yeah they say
everything's a racist microaggression
from stormfront and like
yeah yeah everything she said that's
racist but
the my favorite things that you got
right um specifically i
i was pretty impressed with your when
jonathan majors was announced as kang
and you tied him to the quantum realm
city and you also said that he was
probably going to get introduced to loki
and so
it looks like that's actually going to
be the case so yeah it's pretty good
yeah take a bow on that uh thank you i
will yes um
and i a lot of people saw that quantum
realm city after ant-man and the wasp uh
the fact that
it looks so much like chronopolis it was
just something where it's like i feel
like one thing we do well here and all
of us kind of have this skill let me
rock stars is identifying it's like no
it's clearly going in this direction
i know it could also be this thing or
this thing or this thing no
it's obviously if as filmmakers were
like if i'm gonna pull a reference from
the comics i'm gonna pull that one
yeah okay but my favorite
thing you got right is unfortunately
the most troubling thing
that you got right the fact that you
figured this out
says something awful about you what are
you talking about
they have this cipher in the batman
riddles
where a murderer a zodiac style murderer
is putting in this cipher code and it's
for batman to figure out batman being
the world's greatest detective it's a
smart film
it's going to be this big deal just like
the zodiac had this mysterious cipher
and then was
doing these coded messages and you
pretty much before anybody else
decoded this serial killer's message
almost as if you knew
what the code would be because serial
killers have this ability to understand
their each other's ciphers is that the
case sir
oh philippines how would you know you
are making
the same thing that a lot of people
thought that the puzzle
guy who worked for the san francisco
chronicle was zodiac himself what
grace smith himself was zodiac just
because he was familiar with the zodiac
stuff too
oh everyone should be familiar with
zodiac it's like california legend it's
like hewlhouser level california
uh hero avocado eating dog
yeah so he lied still that was the code
and you know a lot of people did kind of
figure this out i was one of the
the early ones and it's not that
difficult of a substitution code to
figure out
you do look for recurring not for a
murderer and
the reason i was able to figure this out
is i just watched zodiac i watch it like
every you watch it every day when you
wake up yeah zodiac is is
one of my favorite movies and there's a
scene in zodiac where jake gyllenhaal
tells tony stark that
i uh how do you find the double l and
you're able to get the word kill from
the zodiac ciphers
because the double l's most common
double consonant in english language
and you can uh verify from there that
there's a vowel that comes before that
and that vowel shows up earlier and he
lies still
and then um because we've done jokey
improv said so many times i would
be like what's a good pun answer that
was probably the answer of what does a
liar do when he's dead he lies still you
know
from that we're able to kind of like
look at some of the other riddles that
are posed throughout that trailer and i
think we predicted like half the movie
so you are a murderer confirmed uh
fun thing about that zodiac thing i
don't know if you guys saw this but that
uh
recently they finally broke a part of
like a recent cipher yeah and he's kind
of stupid you realize like
he keeps messing up in his own thing
which is what made it so hard
so he would like lose track of where he
was in the letter and he would rewrite
the same like word by accident yeah
that's the thing uh
when you try to decode these things any
time we assume like perfection by the
people
who are orchestrating these conspiracies
no most of the time people make mistakes
and that's what makes these things so
hard to figure out and then finally the
last thing here i have it's just uh
for 20 points i do key points on all
your theories
it's just that you uh you did predict
that there would be a tony stark
successor
in rio williams uh as iron heart and
kevin feige just announced her own solo
series i can't believe that's that's
the direction they're going i um we did
a who was be the worthiest successor of
iron man video earlier this year and
riri williams i kind of looked at it's
like she would be a great option she's
like an mit
student and uh she checks a lot of boxes
so it's like hell yeah go with riri
and they absolutely did so awesome so
let's sum up your points are you ready
to find out
how you did let's see 20 points for that
a thousand six for this 441
335 21.6
uh 2289 uh 543
eric we love you three thousand
there you go ah 3 000 points on a scale
of 100 000 possible points
oh that's fair 3 000
uh you live to fight another well
there's always 20 21 right
we'll see all right uh eric congrats on
a uh positive uh average on your year
you did you did pretty solid good work
everybody give it up for eric voss
thanks
the willingness he he uh has to make a
fool of himself yeah
yeah that is required for the job i
think phillip we have time for one more
box scraps question for the year um
and we're gonna stick to this whole
theme of um
you know owning up to mistakes because
that's what you do at the end of the
year and uh
the question is was there anything
ever non-new rockstars video related
that you were ever absolutely dead wrong
about
um let's see um yeah there's i've made
all kinds of everyone makes mistakes
right i'm trying to think of one where
it's like
you're vamping uh well
uh we're going back to me and phillips
improv days at the university of florida
tsf for life that whole choice was wrong
yeah all the job was kind of a mistake
it took no impromptu mistake it got us
to where we are now we made all of our
instructions and
met all of our uh friends and loved ones
through this but um
there was this weird philosophy that i
have and you remember this philip
i was i was president of tsf um at one
point and i had this like
weird um so just to give people a sense
of how it worked
tsf was like our main improv club there
was like you know
75 people who were part of it and you
know there were all these little
inner teams different house teams that
you could audition to be a part of
and because it's such a big crowd it's
hard to stand out a lot of people
break off and form their side groups and
for whatever reason
i hated that i got so pissed off
when people would make indie teams and
be like no no one's allowed to make
indie groups
everyone can only be part of tsf or one
of the audition teams and if any of your
indie teams
take the place of your priorities and
your responsibilities and your
commitment to this club
you are going to be asked to leave your
ndt i was such a
crazy dictator about that and i would
write these long blogs about how
people's uh commitments were in question
if they were part of too many indie
teams i would
form this kind of like ss where i would
be like if anyone hears someone is going
to form an indie team i need to know
about it
and then i'm going to send someone in
there to convince them it was a bad idea
and i had people in the club just be
like what is wrong with you
everyone should be trying to do as many
indie shows as they can and i guess i
thought that like
well if you put an indie team together
and you suck and you put that
show up in front of an audience that
audience will think improv
sucks and no one will ever that person
that audience will never see one of our
improv shows you'll turn them off from
improv
what i fail to believe is that the shows
we were doing were just as bad
and that yeah maybe people shouldn't
spend all their time doing and watching
improv uh
and it took me like 15 years to learn
that
well i'm glad you eventually you learned
that it was very recent but
i feel like you learned that yeah i'm
having trouble thinking about things
that i'm i'm
absolutely like dead wrong about the um
because honestly too many of them are
it's either like i can't think of them
or they're so
bad that i can never tell anyone
uh i could i could be cancelled i could
be killed i could be jailed
uh the only i guess the only thing
that's coming to mind is that there was
a girl that i was dating
during those same same years and she was
way too
good for me like everybody knew that i
would constantly get asked like how are
you dating this girl
like are you paying her what the hell
are you dying and it's a make-a-wish
thing
um i was like yes yes and they're like
still we don't get it
but uh i was trying to do everything i
could to hold on to her because even i
was like what am i doing how do i not
[ __ ] this up
and um it was her birthday and
i was like i need to make a big grand
gesture that's going to be so
cool to do well first of all she she
like went out of town right before and
she went to vegas and
she i i later i'm pretty sure cheated on
me with an
nhl player off there um but
you know what happened to vegas right
yeah yeah uh when an nhl player uh
i mean what a boring anyway um so uh she
comes back and it's already like a
little uncomfortable
and meanwhile i'm like i've prepared
this insane
uh like treasure hunt thing around the
city of gainesville
to um make her like i don't know stay
in love with me or something uh and so i
made her do
so much work about like solving these
riddles and i
and i remember like each one had a
little message to it number one like
resulted in
she found a pot full of dirt and it had
like a special
message on it and i remember that the
the theme on that one because i
overthink everything was like
our love is a seed that will grow one
day it wasn't it was just literally dirt
with like
seeds in it so it's just ugly as hell
and i remember i painted it myself
and she had to drive around all these
things and then the big payoff is that
i've taken her
to uh see a show at the theater downtown
and i'm sitting there in my seat waiting
for her to show up because she has to
solve all the riddles
in order to go in the show so i started
like five minutes
uh before the show starts and i'm
sitting and she's not there and i am not
trying not to give her any clues
and i text her and i was like you almost
here and she's just like
where i have no idea where i'm supposed
to go this doesn't make any sense
and so i'm trying to give her like fast
like solutions to she's like i've eaten
all the dirt in the pot i'm at the
bottom of the pot
i was like you're still on stage one you
were supposed to be halfway across town
and then so i i remember i tell her
finally i'm like okay fine you're
supposed to go to the hip we're going to
see a show blah blah
and she's like what i'm not dressed for
that i was like well did you get dressed
fast and like
i'm like mad at her now that she can't
solve my own stupid riddle
i think i had a typo in it too which
made it worse uh and you're like
exactly she shows up and she like sits
down she's like super annoyed
it's like her birthday celebration and
like she's being really cold during the
whole stupid show some bad show
and then i remember like the next day um
she it just gets worse somehow
she basically breaks up with me she's
like hey uh
i'm not feeling this i think i think we
see other people
and i somehow think i've got one move
here
and i said and i said no
when how about this give
two weeks for you to come to your senses
i i was like maybe if she processes all
of the stuff that i've just done for her
uh and she's like what i'm like that's
all i ask two weeks
oh my god the dirt yeah plus the
hippodrome
oh my god he's my he's my lobster he's
my one
uh and she two weeks
are passing but i'm like i'm like i have
to make absence make the heart go fonder
so i refuse to see her even though
we do a lot of the same activities and
so she
i'm like hiding from her when she's like
walking by in hallways with her friends
and i'm like hiding pretending that so
that she can't see me and stuff
and so two weeks pass and we meet up and
i'm like
well what do you think she's like
absolutely i still want to break up also
i saw you those times you were hiding
from me
you look way lamer uh you're like
it was just another step of the scene
she absolutely went from okay let's
break up
you know and it's not a big deal we can
still be friends two
you are so weird i don't like any of
what happened here
and i think i'm never gonna talk to you
again and she never did
i um love how both of our stories
we um realized we were dead wrong about
something
but in a weird way those stories ended
up being right for us obviously it's
right for you you're in a much better
place that you you you know you didn't
end
up with this person but in a way i was
right that like i
was like i should have expedited
improv's colossal
failure and going out of style but
really what we were wrong about is like
i should just let people be creative in
the ways they wanted to be creative
yeah yeah and i should let girls dump me
you should let girls dump you when they
say
and not say no to them that's what we
were we're both so
terrified of being left alone and not
and the other people not taking our
thing as seriously as we were even
though we were taking it way too
seriously
yes overthinking everything and thinking
that people will see the joy
and our weird tedious activities that we
saw
and that's when new rock stars became us
overthinking everything and people
seeing the joy
we found our lobsters and they're the
subscribers and watchers of the rock
stars
that's been 20 20. uh good work
thank you guys so much for uh going
along with these insane theories thank
you eric thank you for putting them out
there
yeah good stuff i'm excited for 2021 i
am too
movies and tv will be back from the dead
we will see how wrong i was and be able
to make all kinds of crazy new theories
for what comes beyond
get the vaccine yes get the vaccine as
soon as you can
don't be afraid cut in line push old
people out of the way
yeah say you have a pre-existing
condition and that condition is
impatience
and mary steve bergen's uh musical brain
yeah the finished cage
and uh a reminder to everyone be sure to
subscribe here to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me at eavos
follow phillip at philip molina follow
new rockstars on all social medias
uh check out our merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com
uh lots of great exciting designs coming
up in the new year
new latest obsession uh designs for one
division when that comes you're gonna
love it so
uh get some great options there some
great gift options there bye bye
[Music]
you